- So migraine headaches are actually
a lot more common than
many people might think,
and I get migraines as do
12% of the US population.
So this video is me
looking into some treatment
for migraines and it involves
some needles in the head.
So if you are a little squeamish
and this isn't your thing,
then you probably don't
wanna watch this video.
Just saying.
So the exact cause of migraines
is not fully understood
but the symptoms are described as,
"Excruciating pain that
is throbbing or pulsing,
blurred vision, extreme
sensitivity to light,
fatigue, nausea, and vomiting."
There are preventive things you can do
and there are treatments,
but for a lot of people like myself
these things don't always work.
And for me recently my
migraines have been increasing
so I was talking to my doctor about it,
and he had suggested me looking in
to putting a neurotoxin into my head.
This is like botox.
Now, though this does not sound like
the most pleasant thing in the world,
it's actually something
I'm willing to consider
because I do have some experience
with injections into my scalp
because of my autoimmune disorder.
Before the procedure,
I asked family friend and respected doctor
Doctor Henning of Princeton
Dermatology Associates,
to explain how exactly botox is thought
to help migraine pain.
- The mechanism of action for botox
in the treatment of migraines
is not fully understood.
The neurotoxin paralyzes muscles
and it is thought that
its use in migraines
is related to pain transmission
that is reduced when
you paralyze the muscles
around the head.
- So we talked to Doctor Henning
and I think I'm gonna go for it.
I'm still a little nervous
about some of the risks
but it seems to be something
that helps a lot of people.
So we're gonna give it shot.
- Should be interesting.
- It should be interesting.
- Yeah!
- Yeah.
And so it was time for the appointment
but first they cleaned my head a lot.
Next the doctor had me wrinkle my forehead
and marked the injection spots.
And now time for the botox.
(electric music)
The botox as a numbing
agent is pretty incredible.
Surprisingly despite how this looks,
the process was pretty mild.
And in just 15 minutes it was over.
Two days later,
I didn't notice much of a difference.
My face could still wrinkle
and I even had a minor
migraine on day four.
Five days later.
My face feels relaxed in a weird way
and the forehead wrinkles have smoothed.
Three weeks later: final thoughts.
I would say that the overall
experience was unexpected.
When looking up botox
I found two very opposite search results.
Half of what I saw were
more like botox ads
where people just looked ecstatic
to be getting shots in their head.
The other half I found were
tons of horrific photos.
Their eyebrows stuck up here,
their faces frozen in
this really weird way.
My actual experience is
simply a boring middle-ground.
The process was easier
than I had expected.
I haven't had a migraine since day four,
and I am loving this
wrinkle free forehead.
Actually there are some
serious things to be aware of.
You can actually get something
where your eyelid completely droops,
you can hit like a major blood vessel
or something like that.
I mean there are some actual complications
that can happen.
While I'm appreciative of everything,
I feel very fortunate
that I have access to something like this,
it's still nothing to take lightly.
So that's my review;
boring and in the middle
but hopefully it's helpful.
Look at that!
Look at how ecstatic they are!
Amy you see how happy they are?
- [Amy] They are loving it.
- They are loving it.
Who are these people?!